okay I just want to bring you some
breaking news that is uh being reported
by Syrian State media this is coming
through in the wires in the last few
minutes uh about a an attack taking
place a strike on a residential building
in the ma neighborhood of Damascus in uh
Syria this has uh happened in the last
half an hour or so we believe this is
according to Syrian State media they say
it's likely to be an Israeli attack
which is Target a building in the ma
neighborhood of Damascus uh according to
other local media in Syria there were
explosions reported heard across the
capital so that breaking news there for
you uh just happening in the last few
minutes reported there by the Syrian
State media and what they are saying is
the Israeli attack on a residential
building in Damascus as soon as we have
any more on that story we will bring it
to you